foreign
ERS podcast in the Dunya the three
Muslims
around you could make today
unfortunately he's traveling keep him in
your doors
how's it going on
you're gonna have to give me a second
cause
I was eating dog chocolate
and I forgot that it makes your teeth
all black
you got the giggles today bro
[Music]
s alhamdulillah
um
ah bro so what is today's topic do you
want to give a little brief synopsis or
you want me to go and destroy
today we're going to be talking about
hard life lessons from Islam that we
have learned in the last couple years
we're we're not too old alhamdulillah
I'm 25 I'll know you're 29 now right
yeah yeah
but we have learned a thing or two in
our life and
that's what today is going to be on I do
want to start by saying that
a little bit of a preface that one of
the hard life lessons that we've come to
I guess reinforce
is that life is supposed to be hard no
one said life is supposed to be easy
especially as Muslims
when you study this year you look at the
public system's life and you look at all
the other prophets
it was not easy bro matter of fact they
were messengers of Allah
like what makes us think that if their
life was
filled with trials and tribulations bro
and adversity and loss and grief and
sadness and fitna that our lives are
supposed to be getting easier bro
I do think social media has a lot to do
with that because when you go on social
media you look at the highlights to
people's lives you look at the the best
moments you look at the highs you don't
see the lows you don't see when the
cameras are off you don't see uh you
know a normal life
and it gives us this false sense of
I guess
ease and and success and peace in
everyone that we see
but we know deep down our lives are not
always perfect but because you don't see
that you compare and contrast it makes
you feel inferior bro makes you feel
like you're a victim or life is supposed
to be hard
so do you have anything you want to I
guess highlight or reflect on before I
talk about something from the Quran no
please continue though because I I was
uh
not paying attention to be honest there
was something else uh I had to take care
of
was it the the kefir was over the years
so one of the one of the surahs in the
the Quran
Surah Doha you know it's the it's one of
the surahs that Allah has revealed when
the prophet saws was kind of in a in a
state of losing hope you know and he was
kind of like is Allah going to give me
Revelation what's going to happen and
the main takeaway from this is that the
help of Allah is always near and it's
like Allah is making an oath that you
know
it's it's it's soon enough bro like it's
coming very soon the help is on the way
just just don't lose sight of what's
important don't get heedless and it
always reminds me of how people in life
anytime they go through hardships it's
very easy to fall through
um susceptible to uh what was from
shaytan bro that Allah doesn't what if
Allah doesn't love me what if Allah
doesn't is what if I'm too far gone what
if there's no saving me what if this
hardship or Calamity that I'm hit with
is supposed to be permanent and there's
no getting out of this I know it might
feel like that in the moment
but everything's temporary this life is
temporary and all of these things that
we go through in life these hardships
are temporary themselves doesn't mean
that they're here to stay but we got to
stay solid so
I wanna I wanna hear what you think
about all that so far bro
from unhausalized
no I mean
I agree with it 100
I really don't have a
let's just say on it right now have you
heard times in your life bro where you
thought that life was supposed to be
easy and you kind of fell for this whole
like you know perfect fairy tale
propaganda
no I think that's just a mental thing
right like once when things start
getting nice and easy and you know we
enter the good times uh it's almost like
our mind can't
it can't adapt to the things that start
to come its way and then we have to go
to that state where we are all over the
place until we finally
uh you know get centered again
right but when we're not in that Center
place we're over here in our heads like
playing the victim code because we've
been having it so nice and easy
and it's just a mental thing and it's I
think it's like a lifetime before you
get to that point where you're like all
right like it is what it is I'm going
through this test right now and I just
gotta go on with it so you know how
Allah says in the Quran indeed with
hardship comes East yeah one might ask
out of frustration why is Allah even
testing me in the first place so how do
you answer that
he wants to see if you're 100 about it
because bro like when times are good
anyone can say that they're about it
like you're really really about it or
not
hmm I look at the people closest to you
in your life whether it be your friends
or your family
they're closest to you for a reason is
because they've been there to the good
times and they've also been there to the
bad times
so they proved to you they've passed the
test
of the good and the bad and then you see
like all these are actually people that
can be there with me to the good to the
bad and everything in between and the
love like Allah will give us everything
that we ask for and that we just well
not to deserve not because we don't
deserve anything but Allah will give us
everything that we need
but he also wants to see like okay are
you actually 100 about it hmm
100 raw and so after that I genuinely
think that anything good in life that's
worth having it never comes easy bro
like imagine having a good physique
gotta go to the gym it's uncomfortable
imagine wanting to make money you got to
do hard work
even just bringing it down to like
something like where you sleep on like a
mattress
you know like science has shown that the
softer the mattress it's not good for
your spine bro it's not good for your
back and and for your health but when
you have harder more firm mattresses
it's much better for you you know like
things that are soft bro I generally
think it keeps us soft
and movies and Society bro and when you
go on Instagram
see the more that we advance as a
society as a civilization I generally
think that we've been getting more and
more comfortable
of course you want food before you have
to go hunt
no you know just like that bro you go on
your phone you you swipe something and
then you already got food delivered to
your door and get those nice Boba teas
the mango and the lychee there you go
bro
and you want you want intimacy you want
to have a wife before you have to
actually go out there in halal obviously
and get a wife now unfortunately a lot
of brothers are watching Haram and just
easy to just get that dopamine head just
like that
but see if you're suffering with with P
addiction you're watching Haram what are
you doing
click on this link right now over here
the Omar Academy we made this course
it's proven scientifically to help you
inshallah quit P addiction for good
with this being said
on her my next question would be that
okay we understand the hardship is a
part of life and that inshallah will
give us ease with it right
why do you think
a lot of people fail to recognize
the Simplicity of the fact that life is
about tests
why do you think that they still insist
that life it should be easy and they
should deserve having everything just
catered to them
again it's that victim mindset
is that like it's selfish to be honest
but it's they people stay in this victim
mentality and the selfishness that they
had when they were kids and you know
it's understandable when you're a kid
you don't know any better but as you
grow up it's like come on like wake up
wake up and smell the roses like it's
life ain't it's not Sunshine of the
rainbow it's literally tastes like
sometimes it'll be good sometimes it'll
be nasty and it is what it is you have
to be all right with that and this is
this is why Islam is so important
because if you put your trust in Allah
you put everything like you put all your
eggs in this one basket and there's one
basket being Allah Allah will give you
so much more than you ever asked for
you know like
bro
times are tough
you put your trust in Allah it doesn't
mean that it's going to make it any
easier it just means that okay you have
this this thing that you can lean on you
know that it's going to be taken care of
because any any time you're like you
look back into your life everything has
always been taken care of
100 100
right so if you know this if you can
look back in your own experience and
everything has been taken care of
what makes you think
that this is not going to be taken care
of what you're going through right now
what makes you think that what you are
going through right now is the end-all
be-all for you like just really think
about the situation that you're going
through would it actually be the end of
the world if what you are tripping what
you are stressing out about right now if
that were to actually happen would it be
the end of the world
you know let's say you have this guy
who's trying to get married and let's
say that for some reason it gets right
there to the very end but then it all
falls through and it doesn't end up
working do you really think that's the
end of the world
be honest do you really think it's in
the world
or do you think that in and of itself
will be a test just to see if you're
patient or not
I said we know too many cases of this
bro
way too many cases of this subhanallah
protect us
I mean I mean
but it's to drive the point home that oh
we are we're grown now you know like
usually bro usually back then when
people would go into puberty that's when
they would enter adulthood
let that sink in bro like people enter
in puberty like what like 10 years old
11 years old maybe seven years old
sometimes 13 14 years old imagine you
having to become a man of the household
at like 13 years old in today's day and
age not gonna happen because like you
said we live in a very softer stage
where everything is meant to just be
comfortable Comfort Comfort all over
but it's like to understand that back
then this is how it was and now we've
like digressed or regressed into this
point now it's like we have to
understand that okay this mentality that
we have this this state of mind that we
have that we're saying oh well why am I
being tested why am I going through this
why why do I not have this why am I not
experiencing this it's like well number
one you have to understand
like we're saying here that Allah is
going to test you but number two where
you are right now is because of you
it's because of your own actions because
of your own beliefs and all that stuff
so like how it just well the question is
are you really gonna have this victim
mentality when you understand these
things
um
and another thing too bro is Allah has
Divine Standard Time
and the perfect time for something
whether you want it in a Dua or you know
that it's coming up next might not be in
the exact same time that you want it and
it might not look like the exact same
way that you wanted to bro
a lot of times a lot Allah wants us to
have something but if he gives it to us
when we want it we might not actually
value it and utilize it to the maximum
ability imagine if the amount of money
that you guys have now you had that
let's say two years ago five years ago
right we make this example a lot would
you have been able to actually utilize
the amount of money that you have now
five years ago probably not probably
would have fumbled the bag and just
blown it all up just like that
but now you have a little bit more I
guess financial literacy or
responsibility
and you have delayed gratification maybe
not just heedless with how you spend
and that's why Allah bless you with more
however let's say you want more money
now but what if you don't deserve it
what if you don't have that level of
financial literacy where you can use
that money so Allah's withholding giving
you that money and wealth until you're
at a point where you deserve it and you
can utilize it more appropriately
yeah exactly so I know this brother I'll
keep his name out of this uh
out of the podcast because you know in
details you don't want to uh jump into
people's lives like this but he was in a
place where he didn't have much money to
begin with and um every time he would
get money he would always like you said
don't be smiling bro I'm not talking
about myself at all I know I'll be doing
that a lot
all right
anytime mono makes an analogy is always
him
no no no no it's not I'm doing that it's
not I'm done so he didn't have much
money to begin with anytime he got money
he would end up like just blowing it on
things that didn't make sense kind of
like are you saying you know it's uh the
immaturity you don't have that the lack
of understanding the lack of skill the
lack of preparation and all this stuff
and
he told me that what ended up being the
biggest change for him
was understanding that his risk
the amount of money that was coming to
him
it's already been determined it's
already there meaning that like
he's the one that's gatekeeping himself
so when he figured that out he's like
hold up well how am I actually get
keeping myself
what happened I said I'm wondering that
too bro how does one gay King themselves
exactly well you gay keep yourself when
you have ignorance when you have a lack
of understanding because if you are
unaware of what's actually holding you
back how can you change anything
so essentially you are gatekeeping
yourself unconsciously without even
realizing it so his his thing that was
holding himself back is a simple fact
that he didn't know how to utilize money
he got let's say five thousand bro that
five thousand was going to be gone by
the end of the month
and that's that's a simple thing that
every single human has when we have more
we spend more
if you go into the bathroom
and you have five rolls of toilet paper
are you going to use three squares to
clean yourself or are you going to be
using like maybe 10 15 20 squares hey
you got five rows that's okay you could
use extra right
so the the whole point is that like when
we have more we tend to use more because
we think abundance abundance abundance
but when you understand okay it's I have
this much but I only need this much
and when he started to create an actual
like outline a structure for himself
where he was doing x amount of money
here x amount of money the X mining here
but that's when he started noticing the
risk started to come in and the thing is
that the risk was already coming in
he told me that the risk was already
coming in but he he couldn't see it
because again by the end of the month he
was using up all the money and then by
the end of the month instead of looking
at what he received and being like wow
Masha Allah this is amazing he's looking
at what he doesn't have and what he
needs what he thinks he needs so he
instead of being grateful he's being
ungrateful
and then once he switched it up
he had the same amount of the same
amount of money coming in but because he
changed up where the money was moving
now at the end of the month instead of
having no money and now he has some
money so now he's looking at he's like
and you know how Allah says bro if
you're grateful I will increase you so
the simple fact that he he passed this
thing he passed this test that Allah had
been putting on him for a very long time
from what he told me
that's when everything started opening
up when Allah began to open the doors
for him because again Allah will
continue to test you
until you receive the message until you
change what needs to be changed if you
do not change what needs to be changed
Allah is going to continue testing you
again and again and again and again
so
hope that the story has a little song a
thousand percent and to to add to that
point bro to to enhance it
I don't know why there's a misconception
that Muslims think that
all the money's coming from our Allah
the risk is written I don't have to do
any hard work
you know I'm just gonna focus on the
which is not a bad thing at all by the
way but I'm gonna completely let go of
the Dunya I'm gonna completely let go of
striving this Dunya working hard going
out and getting it
and this is not Islamic bro do you
actually if you actually read the Quran
and understand what Allah is trying to
get us to understand in this Dunya alone
is yes
but we need to have a son and excellence
in the Dunya too
when did this become acceptable that
we're just going to be complacent in the
Dunya look at a lot of this
we know about the virtues and the values
of living and dying in you know Makkah
and Medina and the reward for that yet a
lot of them were buried outside of that
bro because they were going out there
and getting it bro they were
establishing massages doing that calling
people to tell heat calling people to
Islam because they didn't just live a
comfortable life they didn't just focus
on the and completely let go of the
Dunya bro mistakes no there's a specific
Ayah in the Quran I completely forgot in
which chapter it is so if someone
remembers this please by all means jump
in and let me know but in the Ayah Allah
says uh after you were done with prayer
disperse among the land and seek the
Bounty of Allah
I think about that bro like after you've
done praying like going and get that
money getting that paper but there's
another point to the Ayah
that is uh it's very important and if
you miss it then you're missing the
whole point of it all because after this
Allah says and remember Allah often
remember me often so that you may be
successful
because what if you do this what if
after prayer you disperse them on the
land you get that money you get Allah's
bounty
but then when you get this money you
forget Allah in the process
that would not be a success
is giving us all of
the information we need to be successful
like you want to be successful in this
Dunya bro Allah is giving you the exact
the blueprint here this is how you do it
um
see it reminds me of this this one uh
this one man by the name of dolcarane I
don't know if you know about him from
Surah al-khaf
he was that very wealthy King that Allah
has blessed you know he was a leader he
had a lot of riches and a lot of wealth
but one thing that you know was
particularly highlighted was his Islam
it's not the you know the money or
anything to find them or made him he had
that he was killing in Indonesia but
when it comes to Akira he had that on
luck too and the people would come to
him and the people would would basically
come in flux bro begging him and asking
him you know please help us you know
there's these Savage tribes you know and
they're out here you know just cannibals
bro just wild complete immorality help
us and we'll give you all of these
wealth they they brought all the money
that they had they brought all the
wealth that they had and we'll give you
this we'll give you that just help us
you know we need you right now we're in
a time of of of desperate need and what
did he say bro he didn't say okay cool
I'll take all of this he hadn't he had
no greed bro he understood that Allah
has already blessed me alhamdulillah
with a lot of wealth I don't need this
that like you have have nothing to offer
bro and right now you're at you know
complete need of how I can help you I'm
gonna do that and then you know he built
that big seal where Andrew are
completely CO2 today until the release
bro but this is a perfect definition or
example of a man that has Dunya but he
also has principles and Islam and his
son and he has that integrity and
character bro and no amount of Dunya or
nafs or anything can corrupt that
you know
I'll make it easy for all of us see it
to this point I'm mean bro and speaking
about
many Hadith Hadith mentioning on the
virtues of reciting Surah kaf on Friday
how it's going to be like a shield or
like a beacon of light from this Friday
to the next so if you guys are not on
that recite Surah
at least once every single Friday
and it should be from what I know after
Fajr right otherwise if it's before Fajr
it's not Thursday but we started after
Fajr
Allah knows best unless I'm wrong uh
because a lot of the time bro I get
confused when islamically like you know
the days are from Maghrib onward so
unless I'm wrong it's after fudger uh
because I do know that one of the Sunnah
or sunnan is to make Jose before you go
to Juma
and I know for the the hustle it has to
be after Fajr so if the same thing
applies here recite Surat al-qaf wants
to start to finish it's not that long
and then I actually reflect on it read
the translation read the meaning if you
don't understand what it is go to Juma
and inshallah Allah will bless your
Friday
from this Friday till the next inshallah
so I have a question
or those being said about trusting Allah
and it says and all this
in your experience
and what you've read
how does one trust Allah
in the most practical
and realistic way I think the first and
foremost important thing I'm going to
mention is to be in a state of taqwa or
consciousness
and nothing is is one and done we have
to constantly be in a state of taqwa is
continuity it's not just you know one
time near and then you're done you
forget it
and the more you rely on Allah
the more you realize that the little
things that are out of your control you
leave that to Allah just like brothers
said a few minutes ago that it doesn't
make your Affairs any easy it doesn't
make everything okay it doesn't change
anything or fix anything right away per
se but you you let go of the things that
you have no influence and no control
over and you leave that to Allah and you
only that also in and of itself helps
you focus on the things you do have
control over because before you're out
here just paranoid and anxious about
everything now you can focus on what is
in your control
supplication you know whether you can
actually do something in the Dunya these
things are in your control
not if you can actually control the end
result if you can actually get what
you're going for or if you're gonna get
it right now
Etc et cetera what about you
they be commenting why are you flexing
your neck bro
I'm really not I'm just little little do
they know bro physiologically he's
extending his neck
then gonna know all that bro I mean if I
were to flex my neck if you
why are you doing this and I'm just I'm
throwing it back bro
um
it reminds me of the man at the time of
Muslim who asked for increased risk from
Allah instead he was told he will have
the fixed risk which is one bread a day
a man started saving half bread
the half of bread saved per day added up
over the years and he became Rich
yeah you see that you see that bro
what we were talking with a hot
Warner
for those of you don't know about this
uh and he was talking about listening to
surawakia every single night
and you know what's crazy is that he
told us this he told us this a long time
ago
and for a while every single night I
started reading uh sudawakia listening
to it
and it's like At first I was just kind
of you know following what he had said I
was like oh reading it every night
listening to every night like it's it's
actually gonna help in this way I was
like okay well I'm just gonna just gonna
go with it and we'll see what happens
right
and as I started going with it it's like
somewhere along the line like it clicked
it's like oh
the the suda in and of itself is not
going to increase me in wealth it's the
simple fact that I'm listening to and
reading it every single day and it's
keeping my talk while the consciousness
of Allah like it's it's there like I'm
always aware and it's making me remember
a lot more and more and more and more
and reflect more and more blah blah and
it's it's like Allah said Remember Me
often so that you may be successful and
it's crazy because I realize like ah
this is what it's doing
and then for some I don't know what it
was bro but for some reason I just
stopped I stopped reading it I stopped
listening to it and then I had to like
come across the Ayah that I told you
where it's like this person a Monster
Land and seek the Bounty of Allah but
also remember Allah while you're doing
so so that you may be successful and
it's like ah like it all clicked for me
it's it's crazy bro it really is crazy
that's the thing bro when you read
sudawaki and you actually Ponder on it
you begin to realize that Angel's right
it's not the Surah in and of itself that
just magically gives you money or
basically just comes like that without
you doing hard work but a lot of these
things they don't give you exactly what
you want in the way that you want it in
the means that you want it but it
changes your Consciousness
same with this Dakota bro a lot of the
time when I pray Sahara four signs from
Allah right
obviously you know make will do get
ready to praise how to make money or
just like any other any other prayer I
do my turaka I make Dua and sujood Ya
Allah help me pick between This and That
A and B and then I'll read the authentic
at the end of it
and then I expect that you know what
just like every other time I'm gonna get
a clear sign for either A or B and go to
sleep I'll wake up the next day bro many
a times I don't wake up with clear signs
for a or b rather what I do is I wake up
with an elevated level of Consciousness
missed out upon me by Allah and this
elevated Consciousness helps me see
things amongst the nuances between the
two choices that I didn't perceive
before it's almost like I was too
focused on specific things and I had a
magnifying glass but then Allah now
gives me like a bird's eye view on
everything you know and I didn't have
this before
so now instead of getting clear signs
I'm able to come to conclusions and
connect dots that I couldn't do before
and this gift of elevated Consciousness
if you guys have ever in you know
experienced it you know what I'm talking
about feels really good it feels very
empowering and it feels like you're
unstoppable you could see things from a
from a completely different perspective
than you could see before and this in
and of itself is a gift from Allah yeah
this is what gratitude is so important
and we have to be grateful for whatever
Allah gives us because we ask for one
thing but really like that might not be
the thing that's meant for us or that
might not be the thing that's best
for us you know and we might be so
fixated on that one thing but it's like
Allah is the best planet we plan one
thing our love plan is another and Allah
is the best planets and if Allah is
going to give us something which is far
better than what we're asking for like
we need to be open to that and the only
way to be open to that is to be grateful
for anything that Allah is throwing in
our Direction
and you can only do this
if you are aware
if you are conscious
100 and in surawaki bro one of the one
of the things that I always reflect on
is how Allah describes the people that
are basically categorized into three
classifications right yeah and there's
like basically the people that are like
just
you know you don't even want to talk
about where they're going to end up bro
the left they're basically failing to
recognize the things that Allah wants us
to recognize the things that it's most
befitting for us to recognize they're
not operating at the high standard for
themselves perhaps they don't even have
a standard to begin with and then you
got the right you know who's the right
the right are the
this is the Muslims you know the ones
who submit to Allah and uh do acts of
good and worship Allah alone uh do
sadhika and other good stuff that
Muslims do and then you have the
before you even go into the before
Arnold even brings up the last category
bro when I first read this and I looked
at the second category which is the
right I'm already thinking like this is
the cream of the crop bro this is like
the best of the best this is like when
Allah is describing the categories and
traits and and you know the description
of this this right this group I'm like
yo they're so different from the left
they're antithetical to the left these
people are establishing prayer these
people are giving zakat these people are
giving sadaka these people are honest
these people are believers so Allah is
definitely now Allah is going to mention
most likely I thought someone who's kind
of in the middle but then what does
Allah say bro he mentions the cream of
the crop
the top of the top and these are the
forerunners the meanings the true true
believers of all the Muslims and and he
says that
amongst these people there will be a
large group of them from the people
before
and a few of the people from now
and the people of the right there will
be a large group of them from now
and um I think it's a few from before if
I remember correlative so I'm not
remembering that correctly by all means
like correct me
um but yeah it's beautiful I believe it
now
uh no I don't I don't know if he said
that further left okay but but the left
man it's it's scary when he starts
giving the explanations and what's gonna
happen yeah and Allah knows best but see
understanding this we we begin to make
and I'm not again I'm not a scholar I'm
not a scholar we're not qualified to
make the tafsir
um
make tafsir to do tafsir to basically do
interpretation
and
I do want to say like just from our
Layman perspective and from my Layman
perspective it gets me thinking too that
okay Allah describes the left
and then on the other Echelon upper
echelon you got the cream of the crop in
between this Allah mentions the right so
establishing prayer being a good Muslim
being in a state of Islam submission to
God and following him alone
these things that we think is like an
end goal
bro what if that's just a middle path
what if not alone makes you
neutral that's what you're supposed to
do and Allah says in the Quran that we
did not make Islam except that it's a
middle Nation
you know so it really gets you thinking
that the right could just be in our eyes
you know so in a pedestal you know
proper Muslim you know kawam whatever
what if that's just what's expected what
if that just makes you in the middle
Nation
yeah
I mean we should strive for it but we
should also strive to be a foreruns bro
because these are these are the people
who have dedicated their lives to Allah
like bro they are always doing their
best
to whether it be dawa whether it be
learning or by Islam whether it be
trying to get closer to Allah whether it
be trying to give as much silica as
possible trying to help their brothers
and sisters in this uh Dunya as much as
possible like these are the cream of the
crop though like all the prophets peace
and blessing be upon all of them they
are all part of the Forerunner as well
they are the cream of the crop so
imagine if you have other humans that
are in this category then bro they have
to be somewhere remotely close to that
of the prophets and I'm not saying we we
can be that of the prophets I'm saying
like in our actions in our character in
our Deeds we can be amongst this group
that the prophets are also a part of
so like let that sink in like you really
have to be in excellence like isan
bro like you have to be a reflection of
Islam like spiritual Excellence mm-hmm
and bro who said we can't have it like
generally who said we can't have it who
I know like mentally it seems like it's
it's really far away it's out of our
reach but
no one's stopping you except you at the
end of the day you know and that's the
same thing bro with in Surah Allah says
like did we not guide you when you were
lost when you were astray you know did
we not basically enrich you when you
didn't have anything
and then of course Allah talks about how
you know never we should never take the
rights away from orphans and we should
always help them out because the same
way that Allah helped us out we got to
pay it forward we got to return the
favor
but at the end of the day like
in even in the beginning of the of the
Surah Allah says what's coming the life
that's coming after life it's better
than this life it just to remind us that
yes this Dunya matters but if you live
the Dunya in a way where and I tell a
lot of atheists by the way too because
they're like okay what if I do
everything and then there's no like
there's no Jannah everything is just
it's a doubt that some people get you
know and I tell them and I'm like if you
live your life according to Islam right
and we know of course
if we live a proper life but
let's say what you're saying is true and
just uh just the stock follow just to
like you know be Devil's Advocate let's
say once we once we die it's black
screen
you know whatever nothing actually
happens
do you realize you still lived your life
to the best of your ability and you live
the most proper life that you can
you weren't doing intoxicants you
weren't gambling you didn't owe anyone
any money you died in a pure state
like that alone
is amazing is is already a gift it's
already perfect guidance from Allah
you're already living the most perfect
life that you can in Dunya but then the
bonus is you get by the mercy of Allah
inshallah so why would you not want that
I think man it's
it's a process for everyone
because it's one thing to say but it's
another thing that I should live it you
know and
we have to just get to the point where
we are content and I watched this video
of this kafar guy bro and actually
mashallah he had some beneficial stuff
uh but he was saying that like one of
the biggest things that he had to learn
was contentment
and he said that being content is a
skill
and I was like damn well like that's
actually very true you know like a lot
of tell us to be grateful lots of us to
be grateful
but bro being grateful and being content
with what you have like that's a skill
that you actually have to work at that
but if you think about it like if you
can get to the point where you're truly
content and you're truly grateful for
whatever Allah has presented to you like
bro I feel like everything will just be
handed to you like Allah will just hand
everything to you because well you're
passing every single test if you are
grateful and you are content are you
passing every single test there's this
one
uh this is one um guy I think he was in
in Saudi or
somewhere along the lines of the Middle
East and he was working in a factory he
was sitting down and it was like really
hot and he's just he's kind of busted up
bro hey where he's at it's also busted
up he's like really really like working
hard and he was asked like how are you
because like men looked rough
and I'm gonna butcher this but he
replied somewhere along the lines of
like you know what
I'm just I'm so grateful like I'm I'm
sitting down here
and there's so many blessings around me
that they're fighting to get to me and
I'm just I'm so grateful to be here and
be able to be in this position where all
these blessings are fighting so hard to
get to me I'm done with the one I sent
you from uh Sheikh Ali hamura
no I think I sent you this one bro
no no you did send me this I literally
sent you this yesterday bro yeah and he
was like they're literally fighting not
to cut you off but they were like yo
like these blessings are just fighting
and I'm just like I'm literally sitting
and just surrounded just swarmed by the
the bounties and the blessings of Allah
and I'm just like where do I even begin
to start to thank Allah and to be
grateful like where I'm just I just
don't even know where to begin bro and
out here well here
huh
I said and that's different hmm you know
like imagine if we can get to this level
and that that's bro that's true
contentment
if he was asked like how's he doing
because of like how busted up you must
have looked like
in someone else's eyes they probably
would have seen like man this guy's
really bad off like his man does not
have a good life he's over here
struggling he's over here having to do
all this
but in his eyes he's so content and so
happy and so grateful with what Allah
has given to him
that bro like is all these blessings
coming his way like I said the silver
player Allah's giving it to him like
this
um
I mean guys let us know in the comments
if you enjoyed this stream if you want
more streams like this just
dissecting our brain reflecting on the
quota and you know doing open heart
surgery on the heart stuff like that
um like the stream inshallah we will
wrap this up
for anyone that doesn't know because I
keep seeing these comments of where's
rum even though I did mention in the
very beginning of the stream if y'all
just rewind it
arami is traveling today alhamdulillah
keep him in your duas and Ramy bro if
you're watching this make a lot of Dua
inshallah best time to make Dua one of
the best times is during traveling
travel's Dua is never rejected uh this
doesn't mean you're gonna get what you
want because you're a Dua being rejected
or sorry you're the one being accepted
might not mean you literally get what
you want it being accepted is Allah
answering your Dua to give you the best
thing for you pertaining to your Dua
Allah
and a little
I'd say not advice but a reminder that I
want to give to business sisters that
are watching right now is to make Dua
for others
instead of making Dua for yourself I'm
sure that there are some Scholars or
some more that can be found about you
know speaking about this but I found
that whenever I make Dua for others
like anything that I need or that I want
is just pretty much taken care of
without me having to ask for it you know
because it's very selfless it's I don't
even know I'm still trying to understand
it and comprehend it but it's very
selfless when you think about it you're
making Dua for someone else and then
when it's sincere Dua for that other
person
I don't know like I can't help but to
see that Allah sees the intention behind
it and rewards you more than if you were
to have just made the world for yourself
inshallah that's a beautiful point to me
uh to end it on make a new video with
sunny guys you want part four you want
to bring back sunny sunny fast for part
four let us know if you guys really do
want that inshallah we'll make it happen
uh we just had a call with him a few
days ago right just over Zoom
I think it was just us no stream though
each other next time we get a hold of
him we will invite him on and if you
guys want Christian mom too
shallow we will bring her back on
make the offer Sony fans inshallah that
Allah guides him and grants him hidayah
I mean
inshallah stay tuned for some exciting
streams coming up and the exciting
in-person podcast inshallah coming up
too
with this being said I know you wanna
make a Dua
I strongly remember the one that Romy
did but I didn't want to butcher it so I
think I will try to say this one that me
and the brother that I I practice uh
Arabic with he told me and it's uh
[Music]
foreign